good afternoon we start with breaking
news scientists at the uk health
security agency have confirmed that the
polio virus has been found in the sewage
of nine london boroughs
as a result all children in london aged
one to nine will now be offered an
additional dose of the paleo vaccine in
a statement released just minutes ago
the health secretary stephen barclay
said that i want to reassure people that
nobody has been diagnosed with the virus
and the risk to the wider population is
low
vaccines offer the best defense to
children and those around them so i
would encourage families to ensure that
they are up to date with their routine
jabs and to come forward for the polio
booster as soon as they are contacted by
the nhs well let's get more now from our
science and medical correspondent thomas
more thomas this is a big step isn't it
certainly we we haven't had a case of
polio in 1984 and although we
haven't had a clinical case confirmed in
this outbreak the virus is circulating
and beginning to circulate more widely
and with vaccination
rates in the capital lower than the rest
of the country particularly in some
areas there is concern that it's only a
matter of time before the virus would
reach somebody who hasn't had any
vaccination previously and that it might
cause
another case of of paralysis which which
does happen in about between one and a
hundred and one and a thousand of people
who do acquire the virus now the the
vaccine rollout is going to start with
those areas where there have been
samples detected in the sewage
and where uh the vaccinations are lowest
and will then spread across the capital
so eventually the hope that all children
between the ages of one and nine uh will
have been offered a dose and just to to
tell you the areas where there have been
uh
detected there are nine boroughs as you
say and they are barnet brent camden
enfield hackney haringey islington and
waltham forest now this is all related
to
sewage detector uh networks in in
bechten four million uh people are
covered by that sewage plant and the
uh uk health security agency does
routinely measure uh the sewage now
they've had the opportunity to to go
upstream as they uh describe it to try
and identify specific areas uh where the
virus is still circulating and they do
believe that
at least one case has been detected
in in the boroughs i mentioned that
there may be uh other uh viruses
detected in uh neighboring areas of
bechten uh north and east now they're
not sure whether that is virus
circulating within their those areas or
whether it is people visiting
from the other areas known to have
circulating virus and there is still
ongoing work there but what they are
saying is that it's clear now that this
outbreak has gone beyond the original
close network of a few individuals most
likely somebody who's come from abroad
where oral vaccine is still being used
because polio is more common there now a
feature of that vaccine is that you can
release a virus live virus although a
vaccine form of it not the really
dangerous wild-type virus
you can release that into the sewage
system and that does indeed that is why
it was detected but also it means that
it could be spread through hand-to-hand
contact
and also through food and drink and that
is why they're very keen to make sure
that all children do get the opportunity
to have a booster because the vaccine is
extremely effective not only in shutting
down on that outbreak but also
protecting people against paralysis and
clinical disease